my name is Rich debbeck I'm a sergeant
with the San Bernardino County Sheriff's
department and I am currently assigned
as the sergeant uh one of two sergeants
on the marijuana enforcement team indoor
marijuana indoor hydroponic marijuana is
is the best quality and at at one point
it was selling for almost two thousand
dollars a pound so you're talking about
you know
for an example you could say you have a
house that's capable capable of
producing 500 pounds four times a year
and then sell that 500 pounds for two
thousand dollars a pound and if you get
caught it was a five hundred dollar fine
so it was you know it's a simple profit
and loss you know there's there's a lot
of money to be made in the marijuana
world
I believe that there are
Mexican cartels that are funding the
marijuana grows they're probably
funneling the money up into uh
California to purchase the property to
uh to fund all the infrastructure for
the marijuana grow whether it be
greenhouses chemicals generators
whatever it takes to to run the
operation
um but we have not been able to
definitively prove that any particular
cartel is involved we can't make that
link as of yet
when most people talk about gangs they
think about you know the the typical
Southern California gang bangers and
that's not that's not the way it is we
don't see the we don't see the gang
tattoos we don't see the gang
paraphernalia the gang graffiti
um you know mostly what we deal with are
either uh Mexican Nationals or Chinese
Nationals are too
um largest groups of people that we deal
with
so the Chinese Nationals are huge in uh
in the marijuana cultivation World
um my best estimate is probably 97 to 98
of all of our indoor marijuana
cultivations are run by Chinese
Nationals back in 2019 we got involved
in a year-long investigation where we
were able to prove that uh
uh Chinese Nationals were bringing in
money from China purchasing houses in
the uh the Chino Ontario area and
turning them into marijuana cultivations
and we worked very closely with Federal
Partners on that one and we were able to
successfully prosecute that case and
seize all seven houses
you can see the you can see these grows
from miles away and that's why citizens
report them to us so they either try and
not be there when we're there either you
know they'll try and work at night and
not be there during the day but uh
generally there's someone tending to the
grow during the during the day too so
when they see us coming they run off
into the desert which usually doesn't
work out too well you know I said
there's nothing there's no place to go
and no place to hide so you know it's
it's a it's a foot pursuit and we we
catch them and take them back and and uh
you know they're arrested for their
crimes
um on the indoor marijuana cultivations
you know they try and mask the odor
that's going into uh into the
surrounding Community they try and mask
the number of uh
air conditioning units that they have on
the house and and try and make it look
like someone's living there but you know
there there are methods that we use to
detect them and so far we've been pretty
successful